nous allons en débattre maintenant avec
nos invités présents sur ce plateau de
débat doc avec vous tout d'abord Ludmila
akoné bienvenue vous êtes historienne
chercheuse associée au laboratoire de
médiévistiques
occidentale de Paris 1 et vous êtes
aussi une spécialiste de l'Italie
contemporaine paolovic est également
avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste correspondant à Paris pour
l'agence de presse italienne ensa et
puis également avec nous Philippe Friday
bienvenue vous êtes écrivain ancien
grand reporter au quotidien Le Monde
dont vous avez été entre autres le
correspondant en Italie avec cet ouvrage
l'Italie Rome et moi publié chez
Flammarion votre dernier roman
s'intitule lui les amis de passage
publiés aux éditions des équateurs on va
raconter si vous voulez bien pour
commencer la fin de l'histoire c'est un
antibio Berlusconi disparut donc le 12
juin dernier parce que ce documentaire a
été tourné maintenant voilà 9 ans alors
il a bel et bien été déchu de tous ces
mandats pendant 6 ans mais en 2019 il
est à nouveau élu cette fois au
Parlement européen et puis en 2022 en
octobre 2022 et ce jusqu'à sa mort il
est sénateur de la République italienne
donc sa carrière politique n'était pas
tout à fait finie après cette séquence
importante que nous avons vu dans le
film que nous avons regardé ensemble
alors Silvio Berlusconi c'est le premier
ministre qui aura passé le plus de temps
au pouvoir depuis la naissance de la
République italienne c'est
3340 jours passés au pouvoir ça c'est à
son crédit c'est ce qui fait qu'il
marque l'histoire italienne
racontez-nous l'histoire entre Silvio
Berlusconi et les Italiens pour qu'il
puisse afficher ce record
il y a énormément de choses à dire il
faut déjà commencer par le fait qu'il
arrive au pouvoir peu de temps après le
scandale main propre c'est un vrai un
vrai tremblement de terre les Italiens
sont assommés par ce scandale il y a
encore des images vous savez de ceux qui
allaient avec des éponges en dessous du
Parlement en disant vous êtes des
pourris il faut nettoyer tout ça donc il
y avait vraiment un climat très
particulier c'est dans ce contexte là et
la fin de deux grands partis la
démocratie chrétienne et le Parti
socialiste dominé la vie politique
accablé par les scandales donc il est
arrivé au moment où justement la faveur
du changement de mode de scrutin on est
passé d'une république parlementaire
avec un scrutin
proportionnelle à en majoritaire en tour
donc il y a vraiment des changements
très importants il a incarné un
nouveauté qui était aussi une politique
à l'américaine au niveau des médias qui
peut penser un petit peu à oui les
Tycoon à l'américaine il a vraiment
décidé de investir ce terrain sur
l'image mais aussi sur une politique
spectacle et notamment dans le football
aussi avec une façon 86 absolument il
n'a pas un vrai succès ce club il n'a
pas hésité à se faire
parachuter enfin emmener un hélicoptère
directement sur un pelouse de stade donc
voilà tel Dieu qui descend les cieux
donc il y a vraiment une toute une mise
en scène qu'il a soigneusement utilisé
sachant que bien entendu les Italiens et
le foot ça fait vraiment c'est un
histoire d'amour donc il a utilisé tous
les leviers des médias pour pouvoir se
montrer
le jour le plus attaché à sachant pour
les Italiens ça c'est une affaire c'est
aussi voilà quelqu'un qui après qui
était la nouveauté à ce moment-là le
changement c'était un homme de médias
qui est devenu un homme politique et il
a promis un million d'emplois il a
promis il a énormément de choses qui
évidemment voilà on sait aussi
certains disent que c'était un candidat
justement à la période que vous avez
très bien décrite un candidat
antipolytique anti-politique par rapport
à ce qui s'était passé avant en Italie
dès le départ il a fait montre d'une
certaine intolérance vis-à-vis des
palabre c'est un des mais qu'est-ce
qu'on a discuté comme ça on est
tellement habitué à mettre le point sur
la table chef d'entreprise mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que tous ces gens
qui discutent autant oui cela démocratie
voilà c'est comme ça il n'était pas
habitué et ça là un petit peu perturbé
au départ donc il a fait un certain
nombre de gars faut aussi il faut le
dire mais il a voulu se montrer comme
vraiment l'homme fort celui qui
incarnait un peu le quatrième le
cinquième pouvoir si vous voulez et qui
a
donné un gros coup de fourmilière son
parti c'était un parti d'entreprise en
partie entreprise vraiment fait sur le
modèle les premiers cas de Forza Italia
était les quatre de sa propre entreprise
ainsi bio Berlusconi qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ceux qui disent et c'est dit
dans ce documentaire qu'en fait il
s'engage en politique
pour mieux se blanchir
par rapport aux affaires
dont il était accusé déjà à cette époque
dans au tout début des années 90 il se
serait engageant politique justement
pour profiter de l'immunité
parlementaire et se blanchir sur les
premières affaires qui couraient déjà
c'est certain en même temps il a profité
de la politique et la politique lui
servait comme caution notamment le
fameux décret de bettylocraxie qui a
permis à Berlusconi de passer outre la
loi anti trust dans les médias puisqu'on
n'avait pas le droit d'avoir une
émission nationale à la place de la rail
il a été vision italienne donc il lui il
est passé outre il a perverti la loi
anti trust il a passé outre et donc on
lui a fait un décret précisément Haddock
donc il a vraiment il s'est servi de la
politique apporte politique a servi et
lorsque à cheval de ces scandales
de la nature du cercle alors c'est là
comment peut-être pour les regards
français l'énigme italienne avec Silvio
Berlusconi alors d'après les documents
dont je dispose il aurait connu 25
accusations 25 procès une seule
condamnation par rapport à ses 25
condamnations et pourtant et pourtant il
aura été celui qui aura été le plus
longtemps au pouvoir en Italie il y a
une histoire d'amour entre les Italiens
s'il vous Silvio perusconi qui lui
permettait tout
en fait quelque part si
autant au pouvoir et au centre de la
politique italienne c'est que quelque
part il a été aussi le reflet des
Italiens il incarné quelque chose de
profondément ancrée à cette époque dans
le caractère des Italiens on peut faire
un militaire de s'élever c'est ça il
incarnait les Italiens les partisans le
long défini par hasard l'archi italiens
et on peut faire 1000 analyses
psychologique du personnage c'est vrai
que sous beaucoup d'aspects il incarnait
un certain caractère italien et les
Italiens beaucoup d'Italiens en tout cas
se reconnaissaient en lui même si la
fracturé le pays comme une pomme parce
que la moitié du pays a été aussi
anti-berlusconienne et une des lectures
qui a été faite et que si
si toi tu mets au sommet de l'État
quelqu'un qui se montre quelque part un
peu plus flexible je veux pas
utiliser l'expression magouilleur mais
un peu plus flexible par rapport aux
règles du vivre ensemble toi italien tu
es automatiquement légitimé
à faire je sais pas je suis propriétaire
d'un appartement au dernier étage d'un
immeuble à Rome
la terrasse elle est elle est du samedi
et moi tout discrètement je me ronge 10
mètres carrés en plus sur cette terrasse
pour ma élargir mon appartement voilà
donc
en mettant quelque part au sommet de
l'État quelqu'un qui se permettait voilà
de
d'en prendre certaines lois sa
légitimait aussi une forme de chez tous
les Italiens donc avec vous l'avez
souligné tout à l'heure 19 lois on les a
monté après lui là
qui lui ont permis de s'auto-immuniser
contre les affaires qui couraient contre
lui il s'est servi donc comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure
du pouvoir politique pour améliorer ses
affaires personnelles oui c'est le
reproche qui a été fait contre Silvio
bellucconi c'est justement celui-là et
aujourd'hui avec tout le respect à une
personne qui vient de décéder qui qu'on
doit c'est vrai aussi que c'est 20 ans
étaient un vrai problème dans le sens
que sa vie privée et elle est torpillée
notre vie publique à nous et ça a été
surtout un immense une immense perte de
temps et d'énergie à une époque où les
priorités de l'Italie étaient autres je
pense voilà à la crédibilité
internationale de l'Italie au marché à
la dette aux problèmes du chômage
endémique et à l'époque etc tout cela
était mis de côté parce que il y avait
eu une forme de privatisation de l'état
de la part de ce monsieur donc ça a été
vraiment une
une perte de temps et d'énergie immense
qui a beaucoup de nuit à la République
italienne mais loser tout c'est aussi ce
qui vous a frappé
ou alors ce que vous mettez ça sur le
compte de litanialité qu'on a évoqué à
l'instant c'est à dire qu'il incarnait
d'une certaine manière ce que sont
réellement les Italiens ça a été votre
perception aussi avec ce regard français
que vous aviez à l'époque sur l'Italie
exactement quand j'arrive en Italie le
15 août 2008 pour prendre mon poste je
conseille je déconseille à tout le monde
de commencer à travailler un 15 août en
Italie ce qui se passe rien
ma curiosité c'est effectivement
Berlusconi parce que j'en ai un peu
assez quand le traite uniquement sous
l'angle de la dérision ces implants
capillaires etc je me dis il y a
peut-être quelque chose à creuser en
plus j'étais journaliste auprès de
Sarkozy pendant longtemps
en France donc ça ça m'intéresse de voir
de quoi cet homme est fait est-ce que et
puis je me rends compte assez vite en
fait que finalement il est assez creux
enfin mis à part ces intuitions
d'entrepreneurs qu'il va mettre au
service de la politique en fin de la
sienne il n'y a pas d'idéologie il y a
pas de
coagulant
il y a pas de corpus enfin bref et donc
ma curiosité va se reporter du coup sur
les Italiens c'est à dire avec cette
question bon il les lise une première
fois en 94 l'expérience ne dure pas très
longtemps
quelques mois bon il perd la majorité la
Ligue lui retourne lui retire les pieds
de sous le tapis le réalise une deuxième
fois où là il fait un mandat complet
mais un mandat complet dont autrement
dit 5 ans qui ne se passera rien non
plus
il est battu aux élections et puis il le
réalise le réalise une troisième fois
avec déjà une connaissance parfaite de
tous les scandales qui peuvent
l'accompagner donc là du coup ma
curiosité c'était c'est porté
ma théorie peut-être que certaines
façons Paolo là déjà dit mais je pense
que les Italiens aiment la politique
comme un spectacle par contre ne l'aime
pas comme une action et que en ayant un
clown c'était encore la meilleure
garantie que celui-ci ne l'ai jamais et
qui pourrait continuer à faire leur
propre affaire dans leur famille dans
leur ville dans leur provinces parce que
l'État en Italie est quand même vécu
comme comme sorte de passer moins
d'expression mais c'est un emmerdeur
donc c'est quelqu'un qui vient vous
réclamer des impôts etc donc comment
Berlusconi qui a fraudé le fisc dans
toutes ces
capacités peut-il par exemple faire une
réforme fiscale la justice par exemple
comment réformer la justice quand dans
des soi-même le premier client de la
justice les médias comment réformer les
médias quand on est soi-même
propriétaire de médias donc on le reste
quand on est au pouvoir d'ailleurs cet
homme n'a rien fait et d'une la même
façon je pense que pour beaucoup
d'Italiens pas tous heureusement
finalement c'était pas si mal partagez
cette analyse
le but du programme programmatique de
servi obuscule
je pense que ce n'était pas vite du tout
parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier à mon
sens que Berlusconi a incarné un tout
long libéral en Italie qui a été précédé
en Angleterre par Thatcher et parigane
aux États-Unis donc il est arrivé
beaucoup plus tard en Italie pour quelle
raison c'est parce que tant que le Parti
communiste italien était là on ne
pouvait pas faire en tournant libéral
tel qu'il a été fait par virusconi c'est
pourquoi privatisation massive on a il a
accompagné le la voilà la le fait de
enlever du pouvoir
négociation des syndicats et d'une série
privatisation et libéralisation extrême
des médias conflits d'intérêt à outrance
donc tout ceci c'est quelque chose qui
était dans l'air et qui est il
correspond à des intérêts très très
clair donc bien entendu il y a ce côté
il a su se faire aimer par les Italiens
parce qu'il a voulu incarner une
certaine idée un peu folklorique il faut
le dire de l'italialité il faut pas s'y
mettre en pépendre derrière cette aspect
folklorique il y a autre chose il y a un
contenu très clair il y a des projets
politiques qui ont été menés à bien et
bon on peut parler de ces relations
compliquées avec d'autres avec d'autres
organisations voilà on en parlera
peut-être à notre moment vous pensez à
la mafia italienne par exemple
à laquelle il adhère en 1978 la
sulfureuse là je P2 maçonnique ceux qui
ont voté
Berlusconi écouté Marc Lazar les chefs
d'entreprise les petits commerçants les
artisans les gens du Sud plus pauvre
plus démunis et puis les pratiquants
catholiques les femmes oui en partie des
femmes et après si je peux me permettre
les Italiens sont parmi les premiers
propriétaire de leur bien immobilier en
Europe et lui à chaque campagne
électorale et l'hypnotisait l'électorat
italien avec trois mots magiques je vais
couper les impôts sur le logement sur
sur les biens immobiliers et ça a marché
la peau des fesses parce qu'à chaque
fois tous les Italiens même ma
grand-mère disait mais oui mais oui je
vais payer moins d'impôts sur mon appart
elle était trop contente moi je lui
disais mais non non s'il te plaît pas ce
monsieur et en fait même les personnes
les plus
cultivées respectables elles étaient
obnubilées par ce mot magique donc
il y a des mesures qu'on peut qualifier
peut-être de populistes vis-à-vis d'un
électorat populaire des mesures
libérales destinées à cet électorat des
petites et moyennes entreprises et
petits artisans commerçants
et puis les valeurs morales du
catholicisme qui qui sur lequel il
catholicisme voilà j'ai mes réserves
dans le sens qu'on l'Italie il y a aussi
ce qu'on appelle entre guillemets le
Catteau communisme c'est-à-dire le
catholicisme de gauche qui lui en
revanche a été très antiberlusconien
donc voilà le monde catholique c'est
fracturé de façon assez importante face
à l'avènement de Berlusconi mais après
je pense que une des clés fondamentales
de son succès a été aussi cette
révolution linguistique qu'il a fait
qu'il a fait c'est à dire que il a porté
ensuite aujourd'hui avec le recul en se
rend compte qu'il n'a été seulement un
précurseur d'un phénomène
qui ensuite s'est répandu aux autres
démocraties occidentales pensées par
exemple à Trappes mais c'est qu'il a
complètement changé le langage de la
politique c'est à dire qu'à avant
l'avènement de babyconi ont débatté
notamment des contenus des réformes des
politiques etc et lui comme le disait
Ludmila aussi il a apporté ce qu'on a
appelé la spectacle donc quelque chose
de très quelque part il a anticipé le
tweet il faisait des tweets en 220
caractères simplement avec des petites
phrases qui qui avait un effet sur ses
propres médias notamment la télévision
Philippe privée mosquée est important
est-ce qu'on retient aussi lorsqu'on
regarde le dossier berlusconis c'est on
considère que c'est lui qui a unifié la
droite italienne mais pas seulement la
droite parlementaire italienne toute la
droite italienne et en ça il aurait
peut-être été le précurseur et vous avez
utilisé ce mot tout à l'heure de ceux
qui font sauter les digues entre la
droite parlementaire les droites
parlementaires et l'extrême droite bien
jusqu’enil l'a fait en Italie alors
c'est le pouvoir à apporter à son crédit
en tous les cas son crédit de
politiciens c'est-à-dire qu'il a fait
comprendre à ses alliés que on ne
pouvait gagner qu'en étant ensemble donc
avec un attelage pour la première
élection de 94 ce qui est vraiment
curieux parce que donc Forza Italia se
présente une droite modérée il y a déjà
la Ligue du Nord mais qui à l'époque
n'est pas un parti fasciste c'est plutôt
un parti travailliste enfin il y a les
centrices catholiques qui sont aussi
dans cette alliance et puis
les ex MSI donc allez on se nationale
qui qui eux viennent du fascisme
représente plutôt l'électorat du Sud
donc il a additionné comme ça des
marques on va dire et avec ça il a
réussi à faire quelque chose
qui était presque inédit c'est-à-dire
d'unifier la droite et ça et j'ajouterai
que évidemment toutes les droites toutes
les droites et si il avait eu peut-être
en face de lui une gauche qui avait eu
le même réflexe parce que il faut pas à
chaque fois dire Berlusconi est un génie
parce qu'il a fait gagner trois fois la
droite en Italie mais
la gauche parfois gagner et là parfois
perdu et elle ne peut s'en prendre qu'à
elle-même en fait s'il avait pu aussi
convaincre la gauche de suenir peut-être
que les choses auraient été un peu
différentes mais effectivement ça c'est
à mettre à son crédit et je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui peut marcher
pendant longtemps encore et d'ailleurs
la gauche peut peut-être regretter
italienne peut-être regretter le départ
de Sylvie au Berlusconi parce que le
berlusconisme ce que représentait
un ciment assez essentiel dans la vie
voilà c'était le c'était ce qui est une
échelle à gauche
l'anti berlusconisme unifiait la gauche
c'est pas la gauche qu'on traite de
radical en Italie en général il aura
initié quelque chose dans les droites
européennes
cette fameuse alliance de toutes les
droites et notamment de d'allier des
droites parlementaires classiques
libérales à une extrême droite peut-être
qu'on pourrait qualifier de Neo fasciste
en Italie et ça va sur
mélonique l'actuel numéro 1 italienne il
faut pas oublier qu'il a dynamité c'est
lui qui a commencé à dynamiter la
Constitution et les valeurs de la
Constitution italienne née dans la
Résistance et d'ailleurs il a fait
montre à plusieurs reprises de son
intolérance vis-à-vis de cette carcan
qui lui empêchait de faire ses affaires
de faire ce qu'il voulait vous voyez que
qu'il fallait vraiment changer tout ça
et donc c'est toutes au patrimoine qu'il
a commencé à vraiment dynamiter point
par point parfois avec patience et
persévérance et qui est arrivé jusqu'à
aujourd'hui voilà c'est quelque chose il
a le centre de gravité de la droite
italienne à tout de même changé depuis
Berlusconi avant c'était Forza Italia
c'était Berlusconi le centre de gravité
aujourd'hui c'est une droite pluralicale
qui est devenue semble-t-il le centre de
gravité de la droite italienne avec
jadja Mélanie
a aussi gagné parce qu'elle était
nouvelle et il ne sait pas elle n'a pas
elle n'avait pas son crédit toutes les
critiques à juste titre parfois qui a
été faite par les Italiens sur les
magiciens qui ont été au pouvoir et qui
n'ont rien changé qui ont pensé qu'à
eux-mêmes donc il y a ça c'est la
nouveauté c'est une femme elle a jamais
été aux affaires donc elle ne peut faire
que mieux en tout cas pas pire c'est ça
un polydé il y a cette se dédouanement
c'est aussi cette chose choque
n'oublions pas covid crise les unes
après les autres qui font que voilà les
Italiens ne savent plus à quel sens ce
bruit si je puis dire et donc elle
arrive elle est propulsée parce que
c'est Berlusconi quand même qu'il a
gornaqué qu'il a mise le pied à l'étrier
donc elle a été en fait celle qui a
arrêté le premier à la nommé ministre
absolument avis il y a 15 ans je crois
après à montrer des signes d'intolérance
parce qu'il est quand même c'est c'est
le crooner c'est lui c'est celui qui
veut d'être devant sur de la scène mais
c'est lui qui lui a mis le pied à
l'étrier et qui a fait tout le travail
de ça sur les valeurs de la Résistance
et qui a fait un travail de sable sur
toute la représentation démocratique et
syndicale en Italie vous disiez tout à
l'heure que s'il veut bien lesconi il
aura fracturé cette société italienne il
y a les pros puis il y a les Antilles et
d'ailleurs ça va jusque oui c'est pour
ça jusqu'au 14 juin dernier
l'État italien instaure une journée de
deuil national mais même ça ça fait un
énorme débat en Italie au moment du
funérailles de Sylvio
Berlusconi cette fracture de la société
italienne c'est une réalité et ce qui a
eu un est-ce qu'aujourd'hui le
berlusconisme existe encore va continuer
va irriguer ou alors c'est fini il a
disparu avec Sylvio merlusconi mais je
pense que que le parti de force Seita il
était place mais totalement sur son
leader et aujourd'hui il y a une vraie
question qui se pose par rapport à
l'héritage Berlusconi et la succession
Berlusconi personne n'y a pas de
personnalité aujourd'hui en Italie
comparable qui puisse prendre la relève
du cavalier et qui a été vraiment voilà
unique hors norme et c'est vrai qu'il
distribuer lui à la déodorisation de
des postes fascistes qui aujourd'hui
sont au pouvoir avec Georgio mélodie et
il va y avoir je pense maintenant en
Italie une vraie bataille qui va
s'ouvrir à droite sur voilà qui pour eux
cette droite italienne le problème de la
droite italienne par rapport à la droite
française c'est que l'Italie est
orpheline générale de Gaulle
c'est-à-dire en Algérie voilà non
ce n'est pas orpheline n'a pas eu un
général de Gaulle c'est-à-dire elle n'a
pas eu une personnalité qui pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale deux droites se
pose comme antifasciste général de
Gaulle on est on est en pleine
d'actualité parce qu'on est aux
alentours du 18 juin il est parti et
donc la droite française exactement
comme la gauche n'est sur des braises
antifascistes en Italie malheureusement
la démocratie toujours été assez
claudiquante dans le sens que la gauche
italienne est elle éminemment
antifasciste alors que la droite elle
n'a jamais coupé totalement ce cordon
ombilical et donc toute la question est
là et aujourd'hui le grand défi pour
George Meloni je pense que c'est pour
elle aussi une extraordinaire occasion
de le faire c'est de construire une
grande famille de droites en Italie qui
soit antifasciste et européenne puis
privé vous souhaitiez ajouter quelque
chose là que si j'avais encore l'âge de
faire ce métier et d'être correspondant
on est toujours un peu journaliste pour
justement essayer de voir comment va se
passer là la succession non pas de ces
diagramusconi mais comment une droite
modérée que Berlusconi a très très mal
représenté par ailleurs
va renaître de ses cendres alors soit
georgiavelo ni
essaye d'attirer à elle c'était
électorat on se lissant et on voit bien
elle commence à le faire on dit que
enfin
le PPE à l'occasion des européennes etc
mais elle risque aussi de perdre sa
propre base militante qui elle n'a pas
n'a pas ses valeurs du libéralisme
européen etc et je pense que là le jeu
va être absolument
passionnant à suivre pour pour les
correspondants français enfin étrangers
en Italie et pour les journalistes
italiens aussi de voir comment cette
cette place va être reprise une fois que
cet homme qui a saturé le débat qui a
saturé les médias plus encore qui ne les
a contrôlés une fois que le silence ce
sera fait garant aussi un héritage
financier celui-là
6 milliards d'euros c'est la fortune
dont disposerait aujourd'hui la famille
Berlusconi après le décès
la guerre de succession est déjà ouverte
d'un point de vue financier et aussi
d'un point de vue politique sans compter
que la mort de Berlusconi va aussi
déséquilibrer la coalition même si lui
par rapport au ses alliés était un peu
en perte de vitesse au niveau électoral
mais quand même c'est une figure
extrêmement importante et voilà on parle
de remaniement voire il y a des choses
qui vont s'ouvrir qui va prendre sa
place y compris comme en Italie ondy
Gago de la bilanche
c'est l'aiguille de la balance on va
dire celui qui va tenir les choses qui
va qui va faire l'équilibre d'une façon
ou d'une autre qui va incarner aussi la
leadership donc il n'y a personne en ce
moment-là en ce moment qui puisse en
même temps il y a des tels changements
en Italie on se demande à ton vraiment
besoin d'un Berlusconi ou que son
semblables aujourd'hui en Italie ou
ailleurs c'est une question aussi
l'Europe ces derniers propos en faveur
de Poutine après le début de cette
guerre avec l'Ukraine et favorable à son
ami Poutine puisque le considérait comme
un comme un ami ça aura pas non plus
contribué à améliorer l'image qu'on en
avait de ce côté-là de la des Alpes
là aussi c'est la fin de la vieille
homme ou comment il faut l'interpréter
voilà on a beaucoup attribué cette
déclarations sur Poutine et la guerre en
Ukraine une forme sénilité mais bon j'ai
mes doutes parce que même quand il était
dans le plein de ses capacités
intellectuelles il nous avait toujours
habitué à des petites phrases de ce type
ceci dit sur ce sujet là sur la guerre
en Ukraine il a obligé ses lieutenant
genre Antonio Taya et l'actuel Miss des
Affaires étrangères très très liés à
bablusconi à faire marche arrière sur
ses déclarations donc c'était très très
embarrassant ces derniers mois
dit voilà pour tirer aussi une flèche en
sa faveur c'est vrai que Forza
a quand même malgré tout gardé un
ancrage très très fort de l'Italie à
l'Europe et à l'alliance transatlantique
ça sur ça il n'y a aucun doute et on va
voir maintenant qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vont faire c'est successeurs c'est
vrai que j'aurais jamais Loni elle est
aussi dans ce socle elle a complètement
gardé cette continuité pourtant lui a
reproché peut-être en Europe d'être très
atlantiste trop atlantiste surtout au
moment où il était au côté de George
Bush pour faire la guerre en Irak on en
a gardé cette image aussi bien luconi
qu'un très atlantiste
effectivement trois fers au feu on va
dire un faire atlantiste parce que ça
défense dépend aussi de cette alliance
avec les États-Unis un fer tourné vers
la Russie parce que son
approvisionnement énergétique en dépend
et puis un tourner vers l'Europe parce
que c'est d'une certaine façon se
stabiliter politique qui en dépend donc
et tous les politiques italiennes que ce
soit prod ou d'autres ont dû faire avec
cette espèce de Triple Alliance sans
faire de mauvais jeu de mots oui
n'oublions pas d'ailleurs que Berlusconi
était très proche de garde à fille aussi
et que donc il a pas il a été un peu
contraint
à aller
accepter cette guerre vers la Libye il y
a un rapport traditionnel de l'Italie à
la Libye qui est très très très étroit
et qui est voilà qui dépasse les les
cabinets politiques et les mêmes les
majorités il y a vraiment ce rapport
très long sur ça notamment beaucoup
d'analystes aujourd'hui se posent la
question si Berlusconi n'avait pas eu
raison à l'époque en 2011 quand
la France est la en Bretagne avec décidé
d'attaquer Gadafi et les enfants
l'histoire dans ce dossier là à donner
quelque part raison à Berlusconi parce
que elle est droit de l'homme ne se sont
guère améliorées en Libye mais le pays
aujourd'hui on proie à l'anarchie la
plus totale et c'est aussi de la Libye
que partout de de bateaux de migrants
qui malheureusement l'a vu avec
l'actualité récente en Grèce trouve
souvent la mort en Méditerranée donc sur
ça peut-être Berlusconi il avait vu plus
long que les autres je peux pas vous
donner les paroles parce que c'est la
fin du prix des je vous remercie
beaucoup vraiment tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat doc que nous avons
donc consacré à Silvio au Berlusconi
décédé le 12 juin dernier vos réactions
ça sera sur hashtag devadoc sur Twitter
je vous compte sur vous pour réagir à ce
que sont ces réactions à propos de
Sylvie oberlus CONI bien entendu et ça
va faire réagir j'en suis sûr merci à
Selma sali qui m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission je vous donne tout simplement
rendez-vous quant à moi pour un prochain
débat doc et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]